deep into my eyes you're gonna feel a
surge of energy it's a scary moment for
the 18 year old what do you see in
weirdness backstage and she said Chris
can you do something with me you know
and I I kind of got inside her mind and
she saw death in me and she completely
lost her mind she completely freaked out
what death was she talking about I think
that people when they go through a
traumatic experience in their life those
emotions never go away
Paris grew up intrigued by magic she and
Michael both loved Chris's brand of
reality bending they used to watch a
show religiously she wanted to do the TV
show and I had something prepared for
her that I've been working on for 15
years and I wanted to show her father
and her father reached out to me to help
create some of the demonstrations for
his London tour
since Michael died during rehearsals for
his this is it show he and Chris never
got to work together so being with Paris
was like coming full circle was that
people see different things what was
that it's what you saw in me that was
happening in real time like that was one
take on and on just some of the shooting
it with their iPhone it wasn't intended
to be part of any TV show what were you
feeling and experiencing when you were
doing that exercise with her darkness
tonight
Paris is part of angels return to A&E in
his special tricked up she's been very
public about that fact that she's had
some battles with with darkness she has
had her challenges and her own demons
that we all have and you got to consider
the fact that this young lady grew up
with a father that was the biggest star
on the planet
period